CLARISSA WARD: This is the image
the Taliban want to project.
Friendly and pious,
bringing peace and security.
On the streets of Ghazni
city, Taliban official
Maulvi Mansour
Afghan goes from shop
to shop talking to the owners.
- [non-english speech].
CLARISSA WARD: He asks
how the security situation
is with the Taliban in charge?
- [non-english speech]
CLARISSA WARD: The
situation is good.
Praise be to God, the man says.
It may well be a
performance for our cameras,
but it is telling
the Taliban wants
to show they have changed.
When you're talking to
the men and some of them
don't have long
beards, are you saying
anything to them
about their beards,
or does it matter right now?
- [non-english speech]
CLARISSA WARD: We tell the
people that this is the prophet
Muhammad Sunnah, and
make them aware, he says,
but we don't want to force
the people to do this.
- [non-english speech]
CLARISSA WARD: In another
part of the market,
the newly resurrected
much-feared religious police
are also keen to show they
are taking a lighter touch.
They gather the
shopkeepers to introduce
themselves and warn them
about the importance
of following the Sharia.
- [non-english speech]
CLARISSA WARD: Make sure
your women cover themselves,
one Talib tells the crowd.
They should not travel
without a close male relative.
A man stands nearby casually
smoking a cigarette,
a punishable offense under
the previous Taliban regime,
but no one says a thing.
Back at their headquarters
at the Ministry
for the propagation of virtue
and prevention of vise,
the men are still settling in.
- [non-english speech]
CLARISSA WARD: Up
until recently,
this was the Ministry for women.
The man now in charge
seems leery of my presence
and refuses to meet my eye.
- [non-english speech]
CLARISSA WARD: He says
their mission is to help
Afghans embrace Islamic rule.
And what do you
do if they're not
following your
interpretation of Sharia law?
MAWLAVI ABDULLAH MOHAMMED:
[non-english speech]
- We act with accordance
to Sharia law.
Firstly we inform
people about good deeds.
We preach to them and
deliver the message
to them in a nice way.
The second time we
repeat it to them again.
And the third time, we speak
to them slightly harshly.
CLARISSA WARD: If his words
sound like talking points,
that's because they are.
- [non-english speech]
CLARISSA WARD: As
we leave, he hands
us a newly issued
Taliban booklet outlining
the group's gentler approach.
So he says that this book
contains the rules for how they
should carry out their work.
But old habits die
hard, and back in Kabul,
it's clear not everyone is
following the new guidelines.
It's badly bruised.
In a secure location,
Waheed shows
us the ugly marks left
behind after he says he was
whipped by Taliban fighters.
- [non-english speech]
CLARISSA WARD: We've changed
his name for his protection.
He tells us three
fighters stopped
him at a busy traffic circle for
wearing western-style clothing.
They took him into a
Guard hut and demanded
to see his cell phone.
- [non-english speech]
- I had photos in my
phone related to gays.
Also, the clothes I was
wearing were a gay style.
- [non-english speech]
- They took me and
covered my mouth.
Two of them held each of my
hands, and the third hit me.
First with a whip,
and then with a stick.
- [non-english speech]
CLARISSA WARD: What
reason did they
give for doing this to you?
- [non-english speech]
- When they were beating
me, they kept saying that I
was a gay, I should be killed.
- [non-english speech]
- They had very scary faces.
They were enjoying beating me.
CLARISSA WARD: That lurid
brutality was on full display
weeks earlier in the
Western city of Herat
when the bloodied bodies of four
men were hung in public for all
to see.
The Taliban said
they were kidnappers
killed during a raid.
On one man's chest,
a grim warning,
"Abductors will be
punished like this."
Remarkably many in
the crowd seemed
to approve of the
Taliban's medieval display.
- [non-english speech]
CLARISSA WARD:
"People are really
happy about this
decision." this man said,
"because people believe
that by doing this,
kidnapping can be removed
from this province."
In another grotesque display,
two alleged criminals,
their faces painted,
were humiliated
before a jeering crowd.
Punishment the Taliban
favors for petty thieves.
After the corruption of
the former government,
the group has seized
on a frenzie desire
for swift justice.
But they are savvy
enough to know how it
looks to the rest of the world.
- [non-english speech]
CLARISSA WARD: Back in
Ghazni, our attempts
to see that justice system
in action are repeatedly
stonewalled.
We're told that the
Sharia high court
is closed despite the
people waiting outside.
We're trying to show that
you have a judicial system.
[interposing voices]
As we try to persuade
the Taliban to let us in,
we see two men head
into the court.
Our Taliban minder relents
and lets us follow them.
But in the courtroom,
the judge makes
it clear we are not welcome.
- [non-english speech]
CLARISSA WARD: "Tell
them to stop." he says.
We are quickly ushered out.
We've been trying all day to
get into the Sharia court.
They're not letting us, but they
also won't give us a reason.
- [non-english speech]
CLARISSA WARD: It may be
that what happens behind
closed doors here
doesn't fit the Taliban's
new carefully cultivated image.
And that the movement
born in conflict
is still brutal at its core.
Clarissa Ward, CNN Ghazni.